North Korea launched two more
nuclear-capable missiles toward Japan
overnight in response the U.S said the
north should immediately desist from
quote any further provocative actions
State tv showed one of the missiles
being rolled into position right there
Then blasting off Japanese and South
Korean officials estimate the missiles
flew about a halfway mark to Japan
before falling into the sea meanwhile
the powerful sister of North Korean
dictator Kim Jong-un warned the U.S
South Korea and Japan to end a series of
military drills in the area those
exercises over the weekend followed
North Korea's test launch of an
InterContinental missile